he's a man who used his role training
young aspiring officers as a way into
sexually assaulting during his trial the
jury heard how Adnan Ali used the cadet
scheme as a grooming playground a fences
condemned as appalling by the force he
once worked for
it is very shocking and I think what is
first important to identify is that
nobody coming into contact with police
officers or staff
should be exposed to harm and clearly
these young people have had that
experience Ali is responsible for the
offenses that he committed
but I acknowledge that more could have
been done to supervise him
Liverpool Crown Court heard how Ali was
arrested and suspended in October 2018
after police received the complaint he
had been behaving inappropriately
towards a 16 year old boy
after his arrest Electronics were seized
during the investigation officers
discovered thousands of messages and
identified more victims
they're the Trafford volunteer Cadet
program Stratford police station from
2013 to 2018 where he worked with 13 to
17 year olds
his behavior also included sending in
decent images and sexualized messages
an investigation by the independent
office of police complaints found
serious issues with the way greater
Manchester police supervised Cadet
leaders
in a statement it said Ali's disgraceful
Behavior has had a significant impact on
his victims and has absolutely no place
in policing we welcome a range of steps
taken by the force since these offenses
were discovered to improve supervision
of the officers entrusted with this
level of responsibility
greater Manchester police says it's
recommending Ali should forfeit his
pension it's also attempting to remove
officers like him to help try and
restore public confidence in policing
Ali is due to be sentenced in June
shinki marike Sky News Liverpool